alors alors ça manque un peu d'horreur
sur cette chaîne youtube ces derniers
temps vous trouvez pas d'ailleurs merci
pour tous vos retours sur la vidéo
d'halloween c'est un concept qui vous a
énormément plu et ça m'a fait très
plaisir de lire tout ça voilà j'en avais
pas parlé de plus mais sachez le j'ai
tout vu ça m'a fait plaisir aujourd'hui
comme d'habitude trois histoires
d'horreur trois témoignages
flippant pourquoi j'aime bien c'est
lance aussi juste avant de passer aux
histoire sachez que les précommandes de
la bd sont toujours ouvertes pour encore
trois jours seulement voilà ces trois
derniers jours des précommandes je sais
qu'on voit les précommandes souvent on
se dit oh je précommande ray plus tard
j'ai le temps j'ai un mois voilà sachez
que c'est les trois derniers jours donc
je fais un petit reminder après ces
trois jours tous les packs tout ça ça ne
sera plus jamais disponible il y aura
juste une version avec une couverture
différente qui sortira en librairie en
mars et ceux qui leur ont précommandé la
recevront en janvier donc deux mois
avant sa sortie en librairie et surtout
j'espère qu'elle vous plaira voilà parce
qu'il ya plein de retour plein de gens
qui adhèrent au projet mais j'espère
surtout que les histoires l'intérieur de
la bd va vous plaire bref on rentre dans
le vif du sujet on commence par la
première histoire celle de sonia il y a
cinq ans les grands-parents de sonia
décède et elles héritent de leur maison
la maison est belle elle est spacieuse
mais le deuil très douloureux la maison
lui rappelle ses grands parents à sonia
c'est lui rappellent qu'ils ne sont plus
là et ça la rend triste donc elle la met
en vente alors elle va pas la mettre en
vente dans son jus que m'ont dit elle va
la mettre en vente après l'avoir vidée
donc pour ça elle va y passer tout un
week end week-end de nettoyage de
rangement intensif bref week-end visant
à montrer la maison sous son meilleur
jour pendant ce week-end elle fait aussi
un petit état des lieux pour voir ce qui
est fonctionnel ou ce qu'il faut changer
et devinez ce qui ne marche pas la
serrure de la porte arrière de la maison
qui donne sur la cuisine bref on est
lundi la maison est nickel et les
visites commencent la première c'est un
couple avec un bébé qui a
malheureusement trouvé la maison trop
vieillotte pour eux elle est peut-être
encore un peu trop dans son jus la
deuxième visite c'est celle d'un couple
de retraités qui est un peu le
comportement genre que beaucoup de gens
parmi nous je pense qu'on rend visite
c'est à dire que pendant la visite ils
font genre que c'est grave cool qui sont
graves intéressés et après la visite et
donne zéro news clairement ils ont pas
aimé j'utilise ont eu pitié pour sonia
ils n'ont pas osé lui dire que la maison
n'est pas ouf selon eux la troisième
visite c'est celle qui nous intéresse
est celle d'un homme qui a une
cinquantaine d'années cet homme explique
venir visiter la maison pour y emménager
avec sa femme et sa fille et
contrairement au couple de retraités ils
posent beaucoup de questions sur la
maison ce qui est typiquement le
comportement d'un futur acheteur il fait
attention à tous et il remarque
évidemment le petit problème de serrure
sur la porte arrière de la maison sonia
lui explique qu'elle va réparer la
serrure dans la semaine et lui dit qu'il
reviendra pour une seconde vie avec
cette fois sa femme et sa fille c'est la
fin de cette première journée de visite
sonia elle est crevé mais en même temps
elle est contente puisque elle a
probablement trouvé un potentiel
acheteur elle sort s'acheter à manger
elle revient dans la maison elle se fait
couler un bain après son bal se rend
dans sa chambre hélas ses sous vêtements
propres qu'elle avait préparée avant de
se lancer le bain ne sont plus sur son
lit elle comprend pas et cela est allé
chercher et puis lé voilà posé sur sa
commode à un mètre du lit pour elle
c'est clairement une faute d'étourderie
elle est extrêmement fatiguée parce que
je vous rappelle qu'elle est en deuil
donc les nuits passées elle n'a pas très
bien dormi et puis elle sort d'une
journée de visite où elle doit être
maximale doit méga bien vendre la maison
bref elle se dit qu'il est clairement
temps de dormir et elle se met au lit le
matin elle se lève elle commence à
préparer ses affaires pour quitter la
maison est rentrée chez elle pour
retrouver son mari et ses enfants
mauvaise surprise en descendant au rez
de chaussée sonia voit que la porte
arrière de la maison est entrouverte
contraire - sous vêtements pour elle n'y
a pas de doute elle n'a jamais ouvert
cette porte en tout cas elle n'a aucun
souvenir de l'avoir par ferme mais la
serrure étant cassée elle se dit que
c'est peut-être le vent la nuit qui l'a
légèrement entrouverte c'est possible tu
ne regardes pas assez d'eux serait
d'horreur sonia elle repense à sa
dernière visite avec cet homme d'une
cinquantaine d'années elle se dit mais
ces questions est et celle où un peu
quand même le mec lui a demandé par
exemple si la maison était bien isolée
au niveau du bruit parce que sa fille y
jouer quand elle joue elle fait beaucoup
de bruit il voudrait pas déranger les
voisins un peu plus tard lors de la
visite il lui a avoué qu'il était très
content que la maison soit plutôt grande
parce qu'il adore faire des cache cache
avec sa fille bon pourquoi pas à moi
perso depuis conjure in je ne fais plus
cache cache dans une maison c'est fini
pour le moment rien de bizarre juste un
mec attentionné envers sa fille et ses
futurs voisins mais ce lien repenser un
truc qui s'est passé un peu plus tard
lors de la visite comme il n'arrêtait
pas dû parler de sa fille elle lui a
posé des questions tout naturellement
pour en savoir un peu plus sur sa fille
pour créer un échange un peu de
complicité avec un potentiel acheteur et
donc elle lui a demandé quel âge est là
et quand il lui a posé cette question le
mec a réfléchi plusieurs secondes avant
de lui dire quinze ans sur le moment
sonia elle a pas percuter mais pendant
son petit déj le lendemain elle y
repenser elle se dit mais attend quelle
fille de 15 ans joue à cache cache avec
son père et surtout quelle fille de 15
ans jouent bruyamment avec des jouets
comme le mec le lui a indiqué sonia fini
son petit déj en étant très mal à l'aise
parce qu'elle comprend elle sans qu un
truc qui cloche quand même et elle
décide de quitter la maison parce
qu'elle a plus rien à y faire et surtout
elle est de moins en moins à l'aise à
l'intérieur elle a beaucoup de route à
faire pour rentrer chez elle donc avant
de sortir de la maison elle décide de
faire un dernier pipi mais avant d'aller
aux toilettes qui sont à l'état elle
file de hongrie elle sort donc de la
maison par la porte d'entrée la porte
principale en fermant à clef derrière
elle et puis elle rentre dans la maison
manière disque être par la porte arrière
celle qui donne sur la cuisine et au
moment où elle passe la porte elle
s'arrête net parce qu'elle entend du
bruit à l'état et puis elle entend
quelqu'un descendre les escaliers en
courant est ce quelqu'un c'est l'homme
d'une cinquantaine d'années de la
dernière visite de la veille elle le
voit puisqu'il vient descendre les
escaliers il est dos au sahel et il a un
couteau à la main heureusement il se
retourne pas il ne la voit pas il court
vers la porte d'entrée principale et il
se met à la taper avec son poing en
hurlant de merde à ce moment là
sonia est tétanisé est dit mais
j'avais raison depuis le début il y
avait bel et bien quelqu'un ici le mec
est à seulement 4 mètres d'elle s'il
jette un coup d'oeil derrière lui elle
est foutue mais elle garde son sang
froid et elle sort de la maison
silencieusement en passant par la porte
de derrière la porte de la cuisine une
fois dehors -elle sprint vers sa voiture
heureusement garée dans la rue collé à
la maison elle roule elle se garde de
rues plus loin pour directement appelé
la police tout en regardant non-stop
autour d'elle au cas où le mec les bus
ou les entendu sortir de la maison la
police arrive seulement quelques minutes
plus tard sauf que en arrivant
évidemment le mec n'est plus dans la
maison à cause de cette maudite serrure
cassé soignant n'a pas pu en faire mais
le mec dans la maison du coup il s'est
enfui par la porte arrière et la police
n'a jamais réussi à le retrouver ou
avoir des nouvelles après ces événements
sonia a fait installer une caméra dans
la maison elle a fait changer aussi la
serrure de la porte arrière et
félicitations sonia elle a réussi à
vendre la maison bref sonia on est ravis
qu'il soit rien arrivé ce jour là et
gégé l'instinct je réalise de plus en
plus en disant c'est en racontant ses
histoires que je n'ai aucun
d'instinct moi la porte entrouverte
j'aurais 100% je me serais dit ah mais
c'est moi j'ai oublié qu est ce que je
suis bête j'aurais jamais eu le moindre
doute sur une potentielle très forte je
serai pas là pour raconter l'histoire
voilà je vous le dirai à août messieurs
dames il est temps de passer à la
deuxième histoire celle de charlotte
c'est une histoire assez vieille
puisqu'elle s'est passé en 2004 à
l'époque charlotte fnac je vous aime
excusez moi mais je mets mes mains comme
ça c'est pour qui je me prends à
l'époque charlotte n'a que 11 ans et
elle a vécu ce truc là avec sa maman qui
a lui a raconté en fait ce qui s'était
passé ce jour là des années après et ses
bâtons à l'époque ça mais les
parajuristes et travaille dans un
cabinet d'avocats en droit familial ce
soir-là sa maman est appelé en urgence
pour bosser sur une affaire et donc elle
doit se rendre à son bureau pour choper
des documents elles y vont donc toutes
les deux en voiture et en arrivant sur
place sa maman se gare sur le parking
des bureaux et elle demande à charlotte
de ne pas sortir de la voiture et elle
lui dit la vérité elle lui explique
qu'en arrivant juste après qu'elle se
soit garé il ya un homme traverser le
parking et qui monte dans sa voiture et
qu'il est resté là à attendre les phares
allumés alors on vrai y'a rien
d'ouvertement louche ou effrayants
rassurez vous avez le droit de monter
dans votre voiture sur un parking et de
rester dans les phares allumés mais à ce
moment là je sais pas la mère de
charlotte elle a une intuition elle est
en mode mieux vaut être trop prudente
que pas assez après cinq longues minutes
d'attentes sa mère se retourne enfin
vers elle et lui dit bon écoute je n'ai
aucune idée de ce que le mec fait ou
préparent les prend les affaires on va
chercher des documents dans mon bureau
elles sortent de la voiture elle se met
à marcher pour les bureaux urbains pour
à peu près 40 secondes mais à mi chemin
la maman de charlotte lui dit à les
cayes dépêche toi à ce moment-là
charlotte ne le sais pas mais en fait si
sa maman la presse c'est parce qu'elle a
vu l'homme descendre de sa voiture juste
après qu'elle soit descendu de la leur
elle accélère le pas et elles finissent
carrément le trajet en cours une fois
que charlotte et sa maman sont rentrés
elles se disent ok c'est bon on est en
sécurité et elles entendent un bruit et
ce bruit c'est la porte du bâtiment qui
vient d'être franchi par l'inconnu du
parking à ce moment là ils sont en train
d'attendre l'ascenseur qui à seulement
quelques mètres de la porte d'entrée la
maman de charlotte dit bonsoir à
l'inconnu rien d'anormal dans la réponse
de l'inconnu il dit juste bonsoir et
lorsque les portes de l'ascenseur
s'ouvre il rentre en premier et puis
mais son bras devant les portes pour en
empêcher la fermeture automatique et
pour laisser le temps à charlotte et sa
maman de rentrer dans l'ascenseur et là
au lieu de rentrer dans l'ascenseur la
maman de charlotte sur son téléphone et
dia l'inconnu amer je suis désolé j'ai
un coup de fil urgent c'est gentil mais
on prendra le prochain évidemment c'est
du bluff l'inconnu est figé et après
quelques secondes il retire son bras et
les portes se ferment il ya plusieurs
ascenseurs dans l'immeuble donc la maman
de charlotte rappelle immédiatement un
autre ascenseur et le temps qu'il arrive
elle prend le temps de lui expliquer ce
qui vient de se passer est lui dit
écoute c'était le mec qui était dans la
voiture garée derrière nous sur le
parking j'ai l'impression qu'il nous a
suivis à l'intérieur clairement je n'ai
pas nous faire monter dans un ascenseur
avec lui donc ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va prendre un nouvel ascenseur on
va courir jusqu'à mon bureau on va
attendre quelques minutes pour être sûr
de jamais recroiser le chemin de ce mec
le plan se passe comme prévu et quelques
dizaines de secondes plus tard charlotte
et sa maman sont enfermé dans son bureau
elles vont y attendre dix minutes 10
minutes durant lesquelles la manne
charlotte à l'oreille collée à la porte
du bureau pour pouvoir entendre ce qui
se passe dans le couloir et pour pouvoir
prévoir la potentielle arrivée de
l'inconnu s'ils en avaient vraiment
après elle bref dix minutes plus tard
elle déverrouille la porte elle tape un
sprint jusqu'au rez-de-chaussée elle
retape inscrits une fois sur le parking
pour rejoindre la voiture elle passe la
première et c'est chat ou les bureaux à
partir de la charlotte ne va pas parler
de cette histoire à sa mère en plusieurs
années cinq ans plus tard charlotte se
souvient de ce qui s'est passé ce jour
là elle en parle à sa mère sur le ton de
l'humour elle lui dit tu te
souviens quand on a tapé méga parano et
qu'on s'est enfermé dans son bureau pour
rien tout ça parce qu'on m'a tu es trop
de films d'horreur à qu'est ce qu'on
était bête hélas le visage de sa mère
devient tout blanc sa mère c'est que ce
jour là elles ont potentiellement
échapper un truc dramatique et pourquoi
elle le sait parce qu'un fait divers a
eu lieu ce jour là souvenez vous dans
cet immeuble on retrouve des bureaux de
droit familial donc des bureaux dans
lesquels globalement on signe des
documents fixant les termes d'un divorce
y compris la garde des enfants
l'inconnue de l'ascenseur venait donc de
se séparer de son ex-femme et il se
trouve qu'il n'a pas obtenu la garde des
enfants pour des raisons tout à fait
légitime dont on va parler dans un
instant sauf qu'il n'a pas accepté du
tout cette décision il a refusé de
signer les papiers qu'il devait signer
jour là il s'est barré à la moitié du
rendez-vous fou de rage il a donc
traversé le parking pour se rendre dans
sa voiture c'est donc à ce moment-là que
charlotte est savamment l'eau aperçu
pour la première fois et il s'est
défoncé la gueule avec de la
méthamphétamine on comprend pourquoi il
a pas eu la garde après sept des fonds
c'est la gueule il a pris une paire de
ciseaux de cuisine qui cachait dans sa
boîte à gants et il est retourné dans le
bâtiment c'est donc là que charlotte et
sa maman le recroiser sauf qu'elles
n'ont pas vu évidemment qu'il avait une
paire de ciseaux en main l'inconnu s'est
donc rendu au troisième étage de
l'immeuble il a attendu que sa femme
sortent du rendez vous et la poignarde
106 x avec les ciseaux de cuisine et
malgré le fait que le médiateur
assistent à cette horrible scène le mec
continue et de la poignarder encore et
encore et encore bien évidemment le
médiateur rappelle immédiatement la
police qui met encore une fois seulement
quelques minutes à arriver et en
arrivant sur les lieux le mec était
encore dans l'ascenseur avec sa femme
dans les bras ils étaient en train de
l'étrangler alors qu'elle était déjà
morte depuis un bon moment ce soir là
ils ont donc croiser la route d'un mec
qui à seulement quelques minutes plus
tard commis un crime affreux un mec donc
complètement taré et sous amphétamines
avec elle allait se retrouver seul dans
un ascenseur personne ne sait ce qui
aurait pu leur arriver jour là si elle
était montée dans cet ascenseur et si la
maman de charlotte n'avais pas eu cet
instinct incroyable cette prudence folle
alors qu'il n'y avait pas tant de signes
que ça qui
montré qu'elles étaient potentiellement
en danger voilà encore une fois ayez
confiance en votre instinct quand vous
trouvez que quelque chose est louche on
n'est pas à une minute près autant
attendre le prochain ascenseur éviter de
se retrouver coincé avec ce genre de
gros fils de chien pardonnez mon langage
mais c'est horrible ce qui s'est passé
ce jour-là il est temps de passer à la
troisième et dernière histoire de cette
vidéo l'histoire d'axel accès les
français il précise qu'il a entendu
parler du let's not be fr grâce à mes
vidéos big up a toi axel merci pour ton
histoire elle est incroyable aujourd'hui
axel à 28 ans mais l'histoire a eu lieu
quand il avait 13 ans et qu'il était
encore au collège ce jour là il fait
beau et axel est posée dehors avec ses
potes et l'un d'eux a un plan il
explique qu'au pied de son immeuble se
trouve une cave qui n'est pas fermé et
qui serait d'après lui extrêmement gluck
il n'y a pas de courant il n'y a pas de
lumière et il ya souvent un mec qui
s'appelle rabat qui traînent là bas mais
alors qui est rabat rabat est une espèce
de john key qui boit énormément d'alcool
et qui est connu des services de police
pour plusieurs trucs ivresse publique
conduite sous l'emprise de stupéfiants
et comportements agressifs et violents
envers des voisins mais axel et ses
potes et apprennent ça ils se disent
mais c'est génial let's go ou qu'elle
après-midi de folie quelques minutes
plus tard ils sont devant la fameuse
porte de la cave axel et tout à l'avant
du groupe ils l'ouvrent et en rentrant
effectivement l'endroit et de look
axel précise qu'à l'époque dans son
groupe de potes personne n'a portable ce
jour là ils ont emporté avec eux deux
lampes torches qui sont en plus pas bien
puissante bref nos amis tombent dans le
premier couloir et commencent à avancer
le couloir fait cinq six mètres de long
au bout desquels tu peux tourner à
droite et découvrir un nouveau couloir
de 5,6 mètres de long et puis d'un coup
ils entendent un beau premier coup de
stress pour notre groupe d'amis qui est
ravi c'est ça qui cherchait en venant là
comme je les dis arrivé au bout de ce
couloir on peut juste aller à droite est
tombé sur un autre couloir mais quand
ils passent l'angle la lampe torche
laisse entrevoir les jambes de quelqu'un
à seulement quelques mètres d'eux et
d'un coup tout s'accélère en voyant la
lumière le mec se redresse sort la tête
du box et regarde accès les cm tout le
monde comprend immédiatement qu'il
s'agit de rabat il a un regard allumé il
est crade et surtout il a un couteau à
la main d'un coup le silence est rompu
par des hurlements de rabat qui se met à
courir vers le groupe d'amis axel et ses
potes comprennent immédiatement qu'ils
sont en danger là ils sont plus juste
sans avoir des petits coups de stress il
se chie dessus et se mettent eux aussi à
courir et font demi tour et il se dirige
vers la sortie les bruits des pas
résonnent les cris de rabat résonne bref
dans la cave on est passé du silence au
chaos en une demi seconde et dans sa
course axel tourner la tête pour voir ce
qui se passe derrière
constate que rabat l'a déjà rattrapé de
plusieurs mètres et au lieu de suivre
ses potes et se jette dans le box sur sa
gauche deux secondes plus tard il s'en
rabat qui passe juste à côté de lui mais
qui continue de courir à la poursuite de
ses amis il a toujours son couteau en
l'air il est toujours en train d'hurler
mais il vient de passer l'angle sans se
rendre compte qu axel se trouvaient dans
le box axel entend la porte de la cave
s'ouvrir il entend ses potes sortir de
la cave il se penche pour avoir un
visuel sur ce qui se passe et ivoire
rabat rester dans la cave et en fermer
la porte d'entrée axel explique que il a
13 ans à ce moment là et qu'il a beau
faire plus que son âge est un peu
costaud il fait clairement pas le malin
il est plein de regrets malheureusement
les bruits de pas se rapproche il se
retient de respirer et il sent rabat
passait juste à côté de lui pour se
rendre dans le box qui fouillait au
moment où axel et ses amis sont arrivés
dans la cave axel est soulagés mais
c'est pas fini je vous rappelle qu'il
est enfermé avec rabat il va donc passé
trois bonnes minutes complètement
tétanisés à essayer de réfléchir à ce
qui peut faire à comment sortir de cette
merde irréfléchie et réalise qu'il n'y a
pas qu'une entrée pour accéder à la cave
il y en a deux et la deuxième c'est une
porte qui est relié à l'intérieur du
bloc et cette porte elle à quelques
mètres de lui sur sa gauche juste avant
le virage qui mène au couloir dans
lequel se trouve rabat en revanche qu'il
est impossible pour axel de savoir si
cette porte est verrouillée ou non avant
d'avoir essayer de l'ouvrir mais réalise
que de façon il a pas d'autre solution
il prend son courage à deux mains et
silencieusement y sort du box il n'a pas
de visuel sur rabat mais l'entente
marmonné on et s'approche doucement de
la fameuse porte il pose sa main sur la
poignée et il appuie dessus évidemment
ça fait un énorme grincements qui
retentit dans toute la cave est
immédiatement rabasse met à hurler axel
pousse la porte et heureusement elle
souffre il est de nouveau éclairée par
la lumière du jour ça y est on retrouve
la vue et il tape le sprint de sa life
axel rejoint ses potes qui l'attendaient
à l'angle du bâtiment d'ailleurs il
manque une partie de ses potes qui sont
en fait aller chercher leurs parents
pour qu'ils aillent le secourir dans la
cave mais c'est un grand soulagement
pour axel qui explique qu'il a chialé
toutes les larmes de son corps qu'il a
rarement eu aussi peur de tout ça live
il n'a pas porté plainte il a préféré en
tirer des leçons comme arrêter de
vouloir faire des trucs sensationnel et
de se mettre en danger pour ressentir
des trucs et surtout il s'est dit krabal
et oublier son visage deux jours après
puisque c'est un mec est tout le temps
sous alcool etc etc et pas très lucide
il finit son histoire en expliquant
qu'il n'a pas de traumatismes liés aux
cavs en revanche il précise que
maintenant il est papa il a un fils et
qu' il apprend à son fils à être
prudents et à ne pas se retrouver
enfermé dans une cadre avec un mec un
couteau par exemple messieurs dames
c'est la fin de ce serait dommage
j'espère que les histoires vous ont plu
on se retrouve le mois prochain pour un
nouveau sortait des films d'horreur
l'aller les le hollywood sortie des
films d'horreur ya aucun de bon
film d'horreur qui sort ça me frustre
voilà en revanche il ya des bugs bdo les
filles qui sortent
j'ai hâte de lire vos premiers retours
du coup en janvier pour ceux qui l'ont
précommandé jeu
bah voilà on finit sur un miaulement
jumbo parfait à bientôt les speedos
[Musique]